how do you start a business if you're in
midlife I'm going to answer that
question in today's episode of lunch and
earn greetings everybody from Hollywood
California I got a question from one of
my YouTube fans love you guys darko who
wrote in to say hey Evan I'm watching
your videos frequently thanks doc oh
you're doing a great job I've got a lot
of interesting information on your
channel you can start with summary on
business the summer that's awesome i
love it I'm 46 or 26 years of working
experience and I feel ready to do this
step maybe you can make a video response
about starting a business in the mid
life because believe me it takes a lot
of courage to leave behind the normal
working life thanks and wish you are the
best this is an awesome question and
most of the steps are going to be the
same most of the steps whether you're
certain the business as a teenage
entrepreneur for dear old entrepreneur
you know seventy or an entrepreneur you
still have to follow your passion you
still have the model success who you
model might be different now you might
not be able to relate to Mark Zuckerberg
or PewDiePie or teenage entrepreneurs
that might not be your bag you may not
be able to relate to these guys but
looking up to a ray kroc with started
McDonald's and grew it up while he was
in his 50s and Colonel Sanders sort of
KFC in the 60s those maybe people you
can look up to and respect and it's
being surrounded by their stores could
make you feel like them that's possible
like these guys could do it in a much
later stage in life than I could so I
can do it too but most of the other
steps are the same the thing that I find
the biggest difference is now the stakes
are higher because often now you know if
you're 46 you probably have a spouse you
probably have some kids and now if you
go all in on a business and it doesn't
work that's not just you being hurt
that's your family and you have mouths
to feed that's that's a lot of
responsibility and so the solution
around that is to take smaller bets
don't go all in don't spend all your
money don't mortgage the house don't
don't make these massive financial
decisions I could sink your business and
sink your personal life instead what you
want to do is find
find the easiest way to get started and
invest your time and your hustle and
your energy but not invest your money
into getting the business going all
right good luck I'd love to hear more
about the business and how you're doing
and for those of you watching if you
have advice wisdom suggestions or
somebody getting started later on in
their life leave it in the comments
below I look forward to hearing from you
thank you guys peace out from Hollywood
I'll see you soon